when i was a kid and my parents took me
to the ice cream parlor i had one simple
choice to make which flavor did i want i
myself have always been a mint chocolate
chip connoisseur but nowadays when we
walk into a shop the real star of the
show seems to be the toppings fruity
pebbles boba crushed potato chips the
ice cream seems a bit of an afterthought
honestly shopping for a job in the
modern era can feel eerily similar the
salary can get lost in the fray when you
compare it to the flurry of options and
add-ons that can come with a new
position
insurance retirement on-site child care
stock options vacation days tuition
reimbursement bring your dog to work day
phew
obviously it's really nice for people
who have these kinds of things to choose
from but it can make it harder than just
comparing one ice cream flavor to
another but thankfully it's not
impossible and today we will explore the
buffet of employer benefit options and
figure out how to pick the flavor combo
that's right for you
[Music]
have you ever wondered why employers do
this kind of stuff why bother with all
these add-ons fringe benefits and bells
and whistles
one of the key drivers for employee
benefit plans is basic human psychology
according to maslow's hierarchy of needs
we homo sapiens have an order with which
we prioritize what's important to us at
the very bottom of the pyramid you'll
find the essentials like food water
shelter and just one level up there's
safety and security for our ancestors
that might have looked like avoiding
predators or natural disasters but in
modern society how we make our money
plays an enormous part in how we
experience that safety and security when
our income is erratic or we get let go
from a job it can really feel like a
fault line has shifted in our emotional
foundation
prior to the industrial revolution the
majority of the labor force was based in
agriculture on farms your job security
was based on the fact that you were born
into a certain family and by default
your job and place in society was
basically preset but as soon as
industries like manufacturing and mass
transportation took hold there was a new
opportunity for consistent income which
can be pretty appealing when you're used
to hoping and praying that strange
weather or a pest infestation doesn't
ruin your financial security next came
the first defined benefit plan or what
we may think of today as a retirement
plan the earliest private sector defined
benefit plan here in the us was offered
by the american express railroad company
in the late 1800s similar offerings were
also adopted by banks factories and
public utilities the setup worked like
this after you left your job you would
continue to get paid by the company
often a percentage of your salary but
you had to have worked at the company
for a significant amount of time say 10
to 20 years and you usually had to be
over 60.
given that the average 20 year old in
the late 19th century was only expected
to live to around 60 or maybe 65
employers were definitely playing it
safe things really started to heat up in
the 1920s not long after the
ratification of the 16th amendment which
established the perennial favorite the
federal income tax almost immediately
afterwards amendments created a laundry
list of legal ways around it also known
as exemptions one of the earliest
exemptions allowed employers to deduct
whatever they contributed to their
employees pension plans this provided an
extra incentive and the age of
normalized retirement benefits came into
full swing
as you can see what started as an effort
to meet our basic human needs of safety
and security has morphed and evolved
over the last century companies today
keep piling on more and more of these
perks to attract high quality employees
so much so it's getting harder to
effectively compare offers heck i'll
admit if someone offered me a free tacos
everyday benefit i have a hard time
focusing on what i'm actually getting
paid so let's dig into how to go about
calculating your total compensation i
think it's time to
run the numbers
this is taylor they are looking to make
a big move from a sales job to a
management position at another company
they've received two offers that look
pretty different on paper and would like
to compare them side by side
offer one comes from a well-established
online bike sales company we like bikes
they've offered the following a sixty
thousand dollar base salary two thirds
of health insurance premiums covered a
free gym membership and the possibility
of a five percent annual bonus after
their first year they'll be eligible for
10 paid vacation days a year and a 401k
with a 3 match taylor's goal should be
to try and whittle all this down into an
hourly pay rate the hours are capped at
40 hours a week and assuming they work
50 weeks a year that gives us 2 000
working hours annually
just the base alone would come to 30 an
hour the average individual cost of
health care premiums comes to about
seventy four hundred dollars a year with
employers usually paying for 83 of that
tab but remember we like bikes is paying
two thirds so that's worth an extra 247
an hour not bad at all the 90 a month
gym membership tacks on another 54 cents
an hour the possibility of a 5 bonus
isn't a sure thing but taylor feels
confident they can hit their goal so
that's another dollar fifty an hour so
for the first year with the company this
offer is worth thirty four dollars and
fifty one cents an hour or sixty nine
thousand twenty dollars annually in the
second year an extra 90 cents an hour is
added for the 401k match and an extra
dollar 38 for the 10 days paid vacation
which brings the new number to
36.79 an hour or 73 580 for the second
year and beyond now obviously this isn't
money they'll have in their pocket after
every hour of work but rather the
approximate worth of the total
compensation expressed in an hourly
format
let's look at the second offer this is a
tech startup called educatopia with an
open sales role selling software to
schools
they're offering 72 000
base salary lunch in their fancy
cafeteria every day and five stock units
upon signing with the potential for more
to be granted as bonuses
they even offer two weeks of paid
vacation after the first year but right
now there's no 401k match and they only
pay a quarter of the insurance premiums
this one's a little trickier but let's
see what we can do base salary works out
to 36 dollars an hour nice
let's say that lunch is worth 12 bucks a
day times 250 working days a year is an
extra dollar fifty now the covered
quarter of insurance premiums tax on 93
cents an hour bringing us to
38.43 in year one and 40.58 cents in
year two so despite the fact that
they'll be on their own to figure out
retirement savings this is still looking
pretty good not so fast taylor
what if after chatting with a potential
co-worker at the final interview it
becomes clear that the company's culture
seems to encourage working late and on
weekends it's not uncommon for startups
to expect 50-hour work weeks from their
employees if in reality taylor ends up
working an extra 10 hours a week those
hourly rates tank to 30 dollars and 74
cents here one and 32 dollars and 47
cents year two
suddenly the first offer is looking
mighty good again the only thing that
could possibly tip the scales stock
units are a gamble at this point so
they'll have to think nice and hard
about how much risk and how much grind
they're willing to tolerate now we
understand that some job benefits don't
come with a price tag and can't be
crunched on a spreadsheet jobs can offer
benefits like working from home or
flexibility of work hours that are more
of a personal values conversation than a
financial one it's also critical to take
the time to get a feel for who your
direct manager is going to be and what
the growth opportunities are a 2019
study found that 57 percent of employees
quit their job because of their direct
manager as the saying goes people don't
quit jobs they quit bosses remember when
it comes to picking the right job for
you the salary is important but it's not
the whole picture you are giving them
your most valuable non-renewable
resource your time so do your digging
run those numbers beforehand and you'll
be reaping the benefits for years to
come
and that's our two cents
quick before you go do you know what you
want to be when you grow up no matter
your answer we think you should check
out future of work a new six-part
docu-series on pbs voices hosted by
julia and me that explores the real big
work-related questions that americans
are facing today everything from debt
and the gig economy to career identity
and so much more check it out link in
our description and be sure to tell them
that two cents sent you
[Music]
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
patron
[Music]
you